ولكي تحصل بيلوسي على
أعلى وسام مدني في تايوان عن
دعمها لعقود من الزمن للجزيرة ذاتية الحكم
، فهي الآن أكبر مسؤول
أمريكي يزور تايوان منذ 25 عامًا قبل وقت قصير من
لقائه مع رئيس تايوان في
وقت سابق ، قالت رئيسة مجلس النواب الأمريكي إن
زيارتها مع  كان الهدف من وفد من الكونجرس
هو توضيح لا لبس
فيه أننا لن نتخلى عن
التزامها بتايوان
بينما وقفت الصين في طريق
مشاركة تايوان
والذهاب إلى اجتماعات معينة
يفهمون أنهم لن يقفوا
في طريق الأشخاص الذين يأتون إلى تايوان
أعتقد أنه من المهم أن نلاحظ أن
العديد من أعضاء الكونجرس
قاموا برحلات في وقت سابق من هذا العام ،
وأعتقد
أنهم أثاروا ضجة كبيرة لأنني متحدثًا
أعتقد أنني لا أعرف ما إذا كان هذا
سببًا أم عذرًا لأنني  لم
يقولوا أي شيء عندما جاء الرجال
[ضحك]
هذا الدعم المطلق هو الذي
أغضب بكين التي
تعتبر تايوان مقاطعة منشقة وتحتمي
وضعت زيارة بيلوسي للصين جيشها
في حالة تأهب قصوى وأمرت
بتدريبات عسكرية متعددة في جميع أنحاء المنطقة ،
وهي تطوف تايوان بشكل أساسي.